[Musik]
und zum phönix tagesgespräch begrüße ich
jetzt herzlich niels annen spd
staatsminister im auswärtigen amt einen
schönen guten tag
einen schönen guten tag hallo fahnen der
neue us-präsident ist im amt joe biden
heißt er was heißt dass ihrer
einschätzung nach
ja ich muss ehrlich gestehen ich habe
vier jahre auf diesen moment gewartet
ich finde es war eine sehr bewegende
zeremonie
sie hat die demokratie gefeiert und die
demokratischen institutionen haben sich
am ende durchgesetzt
ich finde aber auch eine eine botschaft
einmal an die amerikanische bevölkerung
den vielen corona toten zu gedenken wir
haben ja vergeblich auf ein wort von
donald trump dazu gewartet aber auch
eine botschaft an die welt also auch an
uns diese administration ist zur
zusammenarbeit bereit und das nicht nur
eine phrase ist das hat schon beiden ja
bereits bewiesen mit wichtigen
entscheidungen quasi in den ersten
stunden seiner amtszeit
das heißt sie sagen egal was kommt wir
können miteinander reden jetzt wieder
mit amerika dh die probleme kriegen wir
irgendwie in den griff eben weil man
eine kommunikative ebene wieder
miteinander gefunden hat
das ist meine hoffnung und ich glaube
auch dass die begründet ist alleine die
rückkehr zu einem normalen miteinander
wird ja nach vier außergewöhnlich
schwierigen jahren donald trump als eine
große veränderung wahrgenommen
wir haben ein professionelles team die
ministerinnen und minister alle
verantwortlichen die beiden benannt hat
haben langjährige erfahrungen die werden
ein interesse daran haben auch mit
deutschland und europa
zusammenzuarbeiten wenn ich zum beispiel
an die wirtschaftliche kooperation denke
aber auch an die großen ich will nicht
übertreiben aber ich sage dass hier sehr
bewusst menschheitsfragen wie den
klimawandel ohne die vereinigten staaten
kommen wir nicht voran
und deswegen war es tatsächlich ein
guter tag gestern
sie sind staatsminister im auswärtigen
amt sie haben hier ein blick war das
denn wirklich so dass man mit den
amerikanern jetzt vier jahre kaum reden
konnte ich kann mir doch vorstellen da
sind auf tausende ebenen kontakte auch
persönliche freundschaften entstanden
auch in der zeit vortrag die ja doch
irgendwie weiter gepflegt wurden und wo
man ja doch arbeitsmäßig weiterkam oder
ist das ein trugschluss
nun natürlich haben wir ja die aufgabe
als regierung miteinander zu arbeiten
und zu wählen und das haben wir auch
gemacht
heiko maas hat einen guten draht
entwickelt so außenminister pompeo aber
die erfahrung war jedoch dass wir mit
leuten geredet haben auch unterhalb der
ministerebene
mit uns gut kooperiert haben aber die am
ende auch gesagt haben wir wissen nicht
was passiert wir warten genauso wie ihr
auf den nächsten tweet
und das ist keine form wie man
verlässlich zusammenarbeiten kann gerade
in zeiten in denen unsere demokratien ja
auch unter druck stehen sowohl von innen
als auch von außen der druck auf die
beiden weil man es andersrum sieht ist
jetzt enorm er muss ein geteiltes land
versuchen wir dazu ein er sagt er will
präsident für alle sein
leichter gesagt als getan was glauben
sie wie weit wird der realistischerweise
kommen ich glaube joe biden ist nur
präsident geworden weil er eine sprache
spricht seit vielen jahren die
verstanden wird auch von den
arbeiterinnen und arbeitern die letztes
mal donna shop gewählt haben auch von
den amerikanerinnen und amerikanern die
sich abgewandt haben vom politischen
system
das ist seine große stärke wir dürfen
uns auch nichts vormachen die bilder des
sturms auf das kapitol haben gezeigt ein
teil der anhänger von neun firmen sind
organisierte und gewaltbereite
extremisten und das wird eine große
herausforderung werden
ich will aber auch für uns sagen wir
haben auch bilder gesehen wo sogenannte
querdenker und von der afg ermutigte
demonstranten am rechten rand versucht
haben den deutschen bundestag zustimmen
ich will das nicht eins zu eins gleich
setzen aber unsere demokratien haben
eine große herausforderung zu bewältigen
und wenn wir uns besser absprechen wenn
wir als demokratien zusammenarbeiten
dann haben wir eine bessere chance uns
durchzusetzen
kennen sie eigentlich joe biden auch
persönlich
ich habe schon ein paar mal auf der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz gehört und
war in diskussionen an denen er
teilgenommen hatte hatte auf mich immer
einen sehr auch charismatischen eindruck
hinterlassen und joe biden ist ja kein
unbekannter das ist glaube ich eine gute
nachricht er weiß wie man in strukturen
wie beispielsweise der nato den
vereinten nationen arbeitet er ist ein
alter außenpolitiker der den wert der
allianz bildung auch für sein eigenes
land verstanden hat und das ist es genau
was wir jetzt brauchen denn ich habe
über den klimawandel gesprochen über die
korona paar über viele weitere
herausforderungen die wir nur mit einer
kooperationsbereite regierung in
washington gemeinsam bewältigen können
was wird denn darüber hinaus das sein
was deutschland an amerika herantragen
kann nach dem motto was können wir euch
auch helfen ich habe jetzt leider hier
wegen einer kleinen sind für ihre frage
noch ganz verstanden können was ich noch
mal wiederholen gerne was wird
deutschland beisteuern für ich sage mal
eine gelingende regierungspolitik von
joe biden über die themen hinaus die sie
eben angesprochen haben ja ich glaube in
der tat dass wichtigste was wir
beitragen können ist dass wir unsere
arbeit fortsetzen europa stärker auch in
der außen und sicherheitspolitik mit
einer stimme sprechen zu lassen und
dafür müssen wir mit sicherheit auch den
pfad weiter gehen auf den wir uns
gemacht haben beispielsweise auch mehr
in unsere bundeswehr zu investieren
das ist auf jeden fall eine aufgabe der
wir uns stellen müssen gleichzeitig bin
nicht der meinung wenn wir über
lastenteilung mit der neuen
amerikanischen regierung ins gespräch
kommen dann müssen wir auch über die
lasten reden die wir geschultert haben
im bereich der humanitären hilfe
beispielsweise bei donald trump sich
dort zurückgezogen hat also ein
miteinander ist an dieser stelle ganz
entscheidend aber auch wir müssen
unseren job machen sagt nils an der
staatsminister im auswärtigen amt ich
sage herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
in einem guten tag in berlin
dankeschön wünsche ich ihnen noch danke